morning i feel like we need a drum roll
for this because nate talked about it
last week he sure did the return of the
miz senior golden years pageant over the
hump and prompt how was it yeah nate
just two ques well hang on a second many
questions about this
the two main ones how'd it go uh-huh and
who won oh well these are important
questions now uh it was awesome it was
really great it was as prompt as could
possibly be and i mean that in the most
positive way now before i tell you who
won the evening started with a poem from
the reigning queen lorraine babbitt
someone wonderful magical and sweet
will be crowned this evening
to make this day
from past contestants and members of the
silver tappers in costumes showing off
the paris of yesteryear theme to a
thrilling tribute to the folly bergere
and a serenade from fan favorite bill
watson i know i promised you the
tantalizing swimsuit portion of the
pageant
cameras were snapping all around the
showroom of the saddlewest casino truly
a difficult task for me and fellow
judges mary mancini and phyllis truman
and in the end m.c stephanie elliott
miss senior golden years usa
marla
also also on miss congeniality
i want to mention the other contestants
though because they were all incredible
laura horn brenda faye bolton sharon
crisp and shelly fuller uh by the way
there was a sixth contestant val hallam
wasn't feeling well enough to
participate but she was in the audience
cheering the other girls on
and i have to give a shout out to the
firecracker that makes the entire
passion happen uh bj hetrick she's only
96 years young oh
only 96. um and she's got an entire
staff around here now once you're a part
of this pageant you're never not part of
it the previous winners are on the
committees that help things set up and
they're all wearing their sashes they're
in the showroom at saddle west helping
you get to your seat or telling you go
sit down well you'll be later or
whatever